[Music]  Prince Harry and hip Hollywood  girlfriend make a mark all or both on  the moon through the big question is  where might they rendezvous the prince  landed yesterday on the island of  Antigua for his first stop on his  two-week tour of the Caribbean today he  was casual at a youth sports festival  and yep there was that beaded bracelet  just like the one Megan where's the  palace has stated that Megan will not  accompany Harry at any of his official  events and appearances one of those  events is a concert on Barbados where  Rihanna will perform  let's just say that we're kind of open  bacon might just pop over unofficially  to catch RiRi show